this is just how you attain wealth in
general investing in real estate and
stocks bonds being more mindful of my
business more mindful everything i do is
a business expense you know it's a
write-off i'm super like old school more
so with my safe stocks i found a couple
of gold mines like neo nio which is like
the chinese tesla
um
and i got into the stock market at a
great time this is when covey first
happened with that when it first
happened everything was it's super low
no no the dow jones on the 19 000. right
now it's at like 37 or something like
that so i dumped into it i was just like
i have i'm in this blessed position to
have access to all this extra capital so
i just dumped in it you know doing
certain brand endorsement deals what is
their biggest non-rap check been so far
puma all day